acts and how can you read why and and
you believe that this happened but
generally in this miracle that it
delights us every time people begin to
introduce themselves and they begin to
explain who they are and where they come
from and they begin to ask questions of
one another and slowly over time people
circle back again and again to difficult
topics each time with a little more
empathy a little more nuance a little
more curiosity and our journalist
moderators work really hard to support
this because it's not a debate it's not
a battle it's not a Sunday morning talk
show it's not the flinging of talking
points it's not the stacking of memes
and gifts or articles with headlines
that prove a point and it's not about
scoring political victories with
question traps so what we've learned is
that our state of discord is bad for
everyone it is a deeply unhappy state of
being
people tell us this again and again they
say they appreciate the chance to engage
respectfully with curiosity with
openness and that they are glad and
relieved for a chance to put down their
arms and so we do our work in direct
challenge to the political climate in
our country right now and we do it
knowing that it is difficult challenging
work to hold and support people in
opposing backgrounds and conversation
and we do it knowing democracy depends
on our ability to address our shared
problems together and we do this work by
putting community at the heart of our
journalistic process by putting our egos
to the side to listen first to listen
deeply to listen around and through our
own biases our own habits of thought and
to support others in doing the same and
we do this work knowing that journalism
is an institution is struggling and that
it has always had a role to play and can
we'll continue to have a role to play in
supporting the exchange of ideas and
views so for many of the participants in
our groups there are lasting
reverberations many people have become
Facebook friends and in real life
friends too across political lines after
we closed that first Trump Clinton
project about two-thirds of the women
went on to form their own Facebook group
and they chose a moderator from each
state and they continued to talk about
difficult and challenging issues and
people tell us again and again that they
are grateful for the opportunity to be a
part of this work grateful to know the
people on the other side aren't crazy
grateful that they've had a chance to
connect with people they wouldn't have
otherwise talked to and a lot of what
we've seen and learned despite the fact
that we call herself spaceship media is
not at all rocket science if you call
people names if you label them if you
insult them they're not inclined to
listen to you
snark doesn't help shame doesn't help
condescension doesn't help genuine
communication takes practice and effort
and restraint and self-awareness there
isn't an algorithm to solve where we are
because real human connection is in fact
real human connection so lead with
curiosity emphasize discussion not
debate yet
out of your silo because real connection
across difference this is a salve that
our democracy sorely needs thank you
[Applause]